i'd like you to walk me through what's
happened to you since the events in
evergreen
and and bring everybody up to date on my
end
so man maybe you could start with what
happened at evergreen although i suspect
many of the people watching this
do know that does that seem reasonable
sure um yeah we can we can start there i
think we should um
probably
err in the direction of being
sparse with the details and see where it
leads us
so in 2017 i was teaching at evergreen
as was heather my wife
and she was literally evergreen's most
popular professor i wasn't too far
behind i was very popular as well our
classes were always over full and we
accepted more people than we had to and
had to turn some away anyway
and
then in actually 2016 the new president
of the college george bridges
began an initiative or a set of
initiatives surrounding diversity equity
and inclusion and
these initiatives included the
impaneling of a committee that was
supposed to look into
racism at the college its impacts and to
propose solutions
and as it became clear
what they were alleging and proposing
heather and i became very alarmed
and i began to speak out at first in
faculty meetings and then when the
ability to speak out in faculty meetings
became
non-existent i took to our faculty and
staff email list to talk about the
threat to the college that was
created by these initiatives and that of
course brought about exactly what you
would imagine which were accusations
that i was motivated by some kind of
racism or
white supremacy or white fragility or
who knows what the accusations were
exactly but
but in any case i fought back anyway and
my sense was i had tenure
and i was well liked and i was well
known at the college i had been there
for 14 years and so i didn't think they
had the power to
uh to get rid of me and that gave me the
ability to say what needed to be said
about these proposals
well the upshot is that
ultimately
protesters
50 students that i had never met
showed up at my classroom accused me of
racism demanded that i either be fired
or resign
i told them i wouldn't
and riots broke out at the college in
which
faculty and administrators were
kidnapped i was apparently hunted car to
car on campus by protesters the police
were stood down by the college president
and um
we
were basically left to fend for
ourselves with
student
patrols roving the campus with weapons
baseball bats and the like
so it was a chaotic scene
there was
a lot of interest in it because it was
very colorful but of course most people
back in 2017 dismissed this as
yes an overreaction but you know how
college students are
and those of us who saw it up close knew
that that couldn't be the case that it
would ultimately spill out into
civilization
and
um we of course were right and now it's
everywhere we see it taking over
institution after institution
in the u.s and canada we see
it making tremendous strides in
government and
there's no telling where it ends and
what is
i mean i have a bunch of questions that
come out of that i mean
so i'm gonna i'll lay out three
why in the world did this bother you
enough so that you took a stand
especially given your political leanings
because you were which i'm not
criticizing by the way i'm just stating
that it isn't obvious
to begin with why it would be you that
would take a stand say rather than
someone else but you did and so i'm
curious about why
and
um
what is it that you saw coming
and what is this it that you're
referring to you've had a lot of time to
be thinking about this now it's been
four years and i mean you're and the
other thing i want to ask you about is
your life was thrown completely upside
down you and your wife you don't have
your job at the university anymore
either of you despite the fact that you
were tenured professors um it's not an
easy thing to get another toe hold in
academia once you've been a tenured
professor somewhere especially if you've
gone through what you went through
because no hiring committee anywhere is
going to
give you any consideration once you've
been um
once you've been tired by scandal
regardless of what your role in it was
they're far too conservative to ever do
anything like that and so okay so let's
i don't know if i can remember the order
in which i i asked those questions but
the i think the first one was
why in the world did you
why in the world were you compelled to
to object to object and what is it that
you were objecting to do you think
well it's a funny funny question for you
to pose to me because i have the feeling
that the answer will be entirely
native to you
i literally don't believe i had any
choice people frequently ask me why i
stood up and my sense is if i think
through the alternative
i simply can't live with it i can't
sleep yeah but that doesn't seem to
bother most people so i don't get that
like why why you
well right i mean i guess that's the the
thing i'm discovering
um so you alluded to my political
leanings and you and i both know what
you mean by that i'm a liberal and i
would actually i describe myself
sometimes as a
reluctant radical
um
by that i mean
that i believe we
must engage in radical change if we are
to survive as a species but i also know
that radical change is very dangerous
and so it's not like you know i find
most people who would call themselves
radicals
feel like radical change is always
called for and i don't my my sense is i
hope to see change that makes
civilization good enough that i get to
be a conservative that i get to say
actually we're doing so well
that we have no choice but to preserve
this if we try to improve it we'll mess
it up that's where i want to go
but what i'm discovering is
that
the bedrock of my
liberalism
is nothing like
the
underpinnings of the so-called
liberalism of most of the people on the
left side of the political spectrum
my liberalism comes from
a sense that yes compassion is a virtue
but that policy must be based on a
dispassionate analysis of problems
um it is based on an understanding that
there that the magic of the west comes
from a tension between those who aspire
to change things from the better for the
better and those who recognize the
danger of changing them at all
and
and so in any case i think
the short answer is
we look around the world and everybody
makes
arguments that sound as if they come
from first principles but most people
do not arrive at conclusions from first
principles if they extrapolate at all
they don't do it very well
and that results in
a severe compartmentalization of thought
and that means that when confronted with
um
changes
that threaten a system on which we are
dependent most people don't recognize it
and if they do recognize it they
wouldn't know what to do about it so
uh
how can i how can i put it in in plain
terms
i had no choice because i was as if on a
ship where somebody had proposed to fix
our course through
uh a field of icebergs
and navigate based on some absurd theory
with no grounding in fact
somebody had to object and
i was a little surprised
at how few and far between the objectors
were
but
you know if i'm to be totally candid
about it at the point that things went
haywire at evergreen
i had watched video of you
reacting to protesters in
toronto
and
it had made so much sense to me
at a number of different levels
you know i recognized you as somebody
who knew that although
the initial proposals were
arguably
symbolic that they were connected to
things that ultimately were very much
about an exercise of power and a
transfer of well-being and that it was
therefore
you know you felt obligated to stand up
and say no which resulted as you know
better than anyone in you being mocked
for overreacting and then here we are
years later and it turns out that you
saw with absolute clarity what others
couldn't even imagine yes but i
certainly didn't see what was going to
happen to me
right
you know so
i don't think
it wasn't possible to see what would
happen
with specificity
but i th am i correct in
uh
seeing that you knew
that something very dramatic was likely
to come from your standing on principle
and that
that didn't provide any license to do
anything but make that stand
i i really can't say you know um
it's a it's a while ago now so that
that's part of it but so much has
happened to me that's been so strange in
the last four years that i have very
difficult time making any sense of it i
can't even really think about especially
the last two years
i can't really think about them in any
consistent and comprehensive way i mean
my my family situation has been so
catastrophic in my illness and my wife's
illness it's just been although she
recovered
completely thank god it's just been so
utterly catastrophic that that my my
thinking about it is
unbelievably fragmented
i'm
and i'm i'm
struck dumb still to some degree
by
by all of what emerged as a consequence
of me making the first videos that i
made you know i went downstairs
talked to my wife and my son my son was
living at home at that time temporarily
and i said this piece of legislation is
really bothering me because it
calls for compelled speech and
i looked at the background
documents and
something wasn't right and i said i need
to say something about they said well go
for it you know we'll see what happens
and
all hell broke loose and continues to
break loose for that matter which is one
of the things that's so bloody strange
about it is it doesn't seem to end
and i would have thought when it first
started i thought well you know i'd be a
flash in the pan
for a week or something or two weeks or
a month or six months or a year or two
years or but
it doesn't stop and i really can't
understand that
it's it's beyond my comprehension
now i guess it's partly because i
continue to communicate
my thoughts
to some degree even talking to
mainstream media
people although increasingly less and
perhaps not at all from here on in i
mean i i had an interview with the
london times
two weeks ago three weeks ago it was
published and you know it was just
another complete absolute bloody
nightmare for
my family my daughter in particular
because they
took her to task in an extraordinarily
nasty way
and um you know and the journalist who
did the interview was completely
she you couldn't invent her
you know not only the way she she she
was so deceitful in what she did but i i
learned more about her background
afterward as a consequence of another
journalist who wrote about her and you
know
she's
um a very
singular person to say the least and
so i did feel at the time like you did i
guess that i was more afraid of not
speaking than i was afraid of speaking
and i have something against being told
what to say it's like
i'll pay the price for what i have to
say
i'm not going to pay the price to say
what you want me to say you go say it
yourself
and see what the hell happens
and you know maybe that's just a
kind of
incomprehensible stubbornness in some
sense
um
although i did i think i did
see
what has i did see the beginnings of
what has unfolded since then although i
can't even really
put my finger on what it is that's
happening
so well
i i wonder a little bit about um
you know in some ways
you know there's nothing good about why
you were absent from the scene
but there may be something good about
your having
not been there for every moment of it
and being able to come back to the
discussion with something like fresh
eyes because a lot of this is
developmental
and
you know you say you're surprised that
um
that this is continuing and i must say
i'm having the same experience i feel
like i was picked up you know my whole
family was picked up by a tornado and we
haven't been put down and you know i
sort of feel like
we were joined in the tornado during
2020 it was such a crazy year that a lot
of people whose lives were continuing in
some normal fashion are suddenly aware
that things are
wildly off-kilter and so what was it
like going to teach at grace at grace
church school well it was it was really
nice because i was used to a corporate
environment i guess i you know because
of my time that i had done in a previous
job at hbo
um
i was a technical manager it was a whole
other career
and you know i'm i was i was very
concerned that i reported to the right
people or you know what's the org
structure you know and they were just
like well you know just you have
colleagues and you can discuss things
with them and
we're not going to make you do anything
you can you can talk to us it was a it's
a very friendly
environment i mean there were serious
expectations like you know uh and and
everyone took their jobs very seriously
but there really was a sense of
belonging and community they were very
it was
that was very welcoming actually and
very energizing i will say because i
wasn't used to that i didn't expect it
and so i would be remain aloof from it
you know at the beginning like what's
these people why are they always smiling
at me like what's going on you know like
i don't know why i just but they
gradually loosen up and you
you know it was kind of corny but i
would kind of go along with it and i i
it's a good kind of corny yeah and i did
actually
you know i warmed up a little bit i felt
i did feel like i was
a part of things and i was able to sort
of transmit that to others too
and so what happened
over time
um
it was a very gradual change that you
know i would say
well the within the first three years
one of the tenants of our
our school was that you
every employee and every faculty and
staff member had to attend a seminar
called undoing racism
that was your hr department was it or
who yeah it was it was a you know it was
a mandate from the dean of faculty at
the time and the it was a requirement
yeah yeah and you know um so i went to
that and that was a very interesting
experience
you know it's hard to um what would you
say refuse a call to anti-racism
sure i mean i mean what kind of monster
yeah um and i you know you
i went into it and i actually felt
energized and i was converted you know i
had a sort of
you know i am white and i'm privileged
and you're right we need to take care of
this and there were people in a circle
and people of
all different races and backgrounds and
it was facilitated and
you know later i look back on it and i i
realized sort of how they
how they did it they did it in a very
interesting seductive way
and what way was that
well
you know
as i recall they they started out
um well it was sort of two parts the
first part was the history
since
this you know the slave ships landed on
american soil
and then
throughout time
leading up to the present and then they
focused for the second half of the
session they focused on
you know how to help a community that
has been shaped by all of this and very
early in the very early in the session
they said we want you to withhold
any judgment of anyone's choice or
agency
anyone you know any of
you know the
minority black populations that we're
talking about here
we want you to simply bracket or put you
know hold hold withhold any
analysis of the choices that people make
because you know
they
that will often lead to misunderstanding
or insensitivity towards what's
happening so why do you focus on that
specifically that issue specifically
well because you know
it was as as they retold the history and
as they talk about the present
circumstances they never actually
revisited that so
you you know
you're you're constantly focused on the
oppressed population
in
in terms of what is acting upon it at
first acting upon those individuals
and you know to me that's like
denying a certain agency right and but
they never actually lifted the blinders
off at the end like they they would put
these everyone sort of acknowledged that
they were going to go along with this at
the beginning and i was like really
we're going to do that we're going to
treat people as less than human
well okay i just it must be like a
temporary thing
and why did you see that as treating
them as less than human i mean i presume
that the people on the other side of the
fence would say well
you know we're we're we're all caught
like corks
on the sea in in the throes of vast
social movements over which we have
little or no control and and who are you
to cast judgment on people who have been
um the relative relatively deprived in
that regard compared to you
it's possible to make a fairly stringent
moral case that that's the appropriate
mode of behavior but you were there was
something in you that objected to that
and and you remember that now
yeah
despite the fact that you said that you
were energized by this and pulled in by
it why do you think why do you think it
caught you as well
well
it was a social thing right it was it's
a people in a circle and people are
talking about their experiences and
people are saying as a black person i
have this has happened to me and
at one point they asked they actually
you know they it's it's empathy right
you you care about people you you feel
if you're sitting face to face with
someone of course you're going to be i'm
going to be sympathetic and empathetic
and and people are narrating um
you know but the problem i think is
generalizing that to groups and you know
getting you to make a different set of
assumptions about those groups based on
a sort of
you know selective
way that the empathy is leveraged i
would say well there's also the implicit
there's the implicit
uh what would you say the implicit
perceptual and categorical structure
that comes along with it which is the a
priory assumption that the appropriate
classification for human beings is by
group
yeah and and that that that's so
implicit but so pervasive that it in
some sense never needs to be stated and
as soon as you assume that the group
level is the appropriate level then
you're bound to minimize or even forbid
discussion of such things as individual
agency
so tell us about the blog when did you
start writing your blog in july 2019
and why did you start to do that you
mean you have your research career
you're an undergraduate or you're you're
a teacher as well
you're working in the community you have
a
full life what what compelled you to to
start a blog
i love to write uh and i think it's it's
a reflex that i have from war so i used
to write my my diary in arabic and in
french and i have them with me that came
from with me in a box and went
across three provinces so i love to
write so uh in july 2019 i didn't have
the chance
maybe to say what i wanted to say on a
platform so i decided to have my own
blog and just write for the pleasure of
writing i write about lebanon
maybe half of the time i write about
canada quebec here
i just write
and express
views
in relation to what is happening
in canada and in the world and i think
i'm seeing something very worrisome and
maybe that's part of why maybe i'm
writing because i'm seeing that we are
in times where
we can't talk about things like look
what's happening in my story like we
people are afraid
they may think things um when they are
at home privately but they may not
express them publicly
or maybe because of you know political
correctness or whatever i'm not that
type of person like what i write or
bambi the name of the person writing is
actually the meaning of my first name
rima it means a little deer in arabic
and bambi is that deer so bambi's afkar
are bambi's thoughts so i i what i write
is actually who whom i am what my own
thoughts uh
privately and on that blog
i sometimes write maybe you know
personal things about birthdays of loved
ones or whatever it's a blog right so
that's it
and what kind of audience does your blog
have
well at first i thought it had maybe 10
people maybe first myself i was writing
for myself but i thought family family
members and then when that story
happened uh i for once i searched i
usually don't have the time to do that
and i thought it was like really getting
2 000
on one day and then like i don't know
another day i checked 500 something like
that i thought oh my goodness like i was
really thinking i'm writing you know i'm
using uh
during the pandemic my in-laws or my
parents sometimes with some some issues
or writing about the beirut explosion i
interviewed friends about what they are
going through the financial crisis you
know things like that
right so it had expanded beyond the
small number of people that you had
assumed were reading it absolutely
exactly what happened to you so
you were you were living what i would
presume was a pretty comfortable and
happy life as you've described being a
teacher and a researcher you spun off
this blog on the side
and then what happened one day
you were notified by the university
tell us exactly the story i can tell you
but i want to say yes i'm extremely
happy even in the pandemic even despite
the beirut explosion and everything like
i'm finding my ways of you know living
coping with new brunswick is amazing um
for canada but but we're also lucky to
be in the semi-raw
areas where even the pandemic did not
hit us as hard as as strong or bigger
places in montreal
so in that sense um it was all okay
until that february 22nd
where i can tell you that story because
it's my story that's my part so and and
it's in the media actually i was um i'm
i was having symptoms of actually like
covet 19 i wasn't sure and i was very
very very sick and not i usually run
fast and jump and go on the stairs and i
couldn't take the stairs i would stop
you know couldn't breathe and uh so on
that day the monday where it happened i
went for testing was finally negative
but i went came back did my work day and
then and the at the end of the day i was
lying on the couch thinking that i was
resting i got a phone call
from a kind former student telling me dr
azar you're uh
you need to know what is happening and i
thought are you okay what is happening
was worried
uh and he said no i'm fine you are in
trouble in big trouble so the story
started in the social media i'm not on
social media myself um so for me i chose
that blog because it's what suits my
personality what i'm you know writing
and having an enough space to write and
so anyways i enjoy reading social media
and i do but i i'm not on it so so i
went i read quickly and i thought okay
you know it was there and this was where
this was on twitter this was all
happening on twitter or where was it i
don't know if it was happening on on
elsewhere as a facebook i guess but i
saw the twitter myself
and then an email got out of the
university uh publicly so not on twitter
on facebook um or the public channels of
the university
saying um you know it's public so i'm
not saying what is not public um trigger
warning that blog we dissociate
ourselves from it and and you know uh
all and encouraging complaints
okay so what people what were people
saying on twitter and who who was it
that would say it and how many of them
were there do you know a lot uh and like
it was it was a big thing on social
media like um and and there has been
also at one point you know a threat of
violence on social media and things like
that so it was it was
then i don't want to forget that part
when the
there were three student organizations
asked for my removal from
my position
at my university and also
affiliations uh elsewhere like
university of new brunswick invested in
mountain as well uh so it got really
okay so i want to zero in on this so
there's there's some students primarily
on social media on twitter primarily and
they're complaining about your blog
and they're students who are part of
student organizations and do you and
then the student organizations
themselves three of them
are contacting your the people that
you're working for or with
suggesting that you're not the sort of
person they should be associating with
and asking for your removal exactly you
said there were lots of of
students doing this and i'd like to get
something an estimate of something like
a number so does a lot mean 500 or does
it mean five
so in between maybe i don't know
precisely the answer well the reason i'm
asking is because one of the things i'm
curious about is just how many people
have to complain before complaints are
taken with some degree of seriousness
now i've dealt with ethics boards for
example at my own university and they
have a policy that every complaint
should be investigated thoroughly and
i'm not very fond of that policy
particularly because there are a lot of
people who cause a fair bit of trouble
for absolutely no reason and it seems to
me that complaints need to pass
something approximating a reasonable
threshold before they're dealt with
let's say seriously and so you know it's
striking when you're talking about this
that you don't know how many people
actually came after you because they
came after you on on social media and
it's certainly not in the hundreds it's
unlikely to be and correct me if i'm
wrong it's unlikely to be in the dozens
is it is it 10 is it 15
and were they students who were actually
in your classes or were they just people
who read your blog and and what were
they objecting to in your blog exactly
what did you say that was in principle
or do you even know what it is that
they're
upset about what i've read is that you
made some claim that canada wasn't
systemically racist that wasn't the
right way of looking at the country and
is there
so and to me that means now is that the
case now that at a university if i stand
up and say that i don't believe that the
lens of systemic racism is the proper
way to analyze canada especially
compared to other countries that now i'm
so reprehensible that i deserve to be
suspended if a couple of people object
is that the situation that we're looking
at or am i being too hard on the
university
well i think
it's hard to answer that question i know
the numbers that i know uh of now i know
them because of what happened and how
many people but before i didn't know
anything i personally found it amazing
that
my university my employer that i that i
love and respect you know
did not call me to tell me what was
happening that that i learned in that
did your
union my i my union is doing what needs
to be done and i'm very grateful but uh
but i didn't know
about that i knew it that's how i knew
it and then after that first call
friends from nova scotia amherst
hearing in the news on the radio it was
all everywhere um
i have to admit uh i may be wrong but
there may have been a flavor for that
during that month so like it was like
like my story was sort of a
scapegoat for something that is much
bigger than a deer a simple deer a silly
deer sometimes we're not allowed to
write serious things or silly things or
be wrong or change our mind
so what precisely i don't know but i do
i personally am allergic to identity
politics given my background
so i i
may have written things about that or or
about uh you know what it's hard to tell
but you're still not sure you're still
not sure what it is that okay so you're
not sure exactly who you offended or how
many of them there are and you're not
exactly sure why you offended them
and you're so unsure that what you say
is that as far as you're concerned
you can't safely write down what you
think despite the fact that you have
your opinions given where you came from
given the fact that you've immigrated
here that you can take a look at canada
from the perspective of an insider and
an outsider you're not sure what your
crime is
no but now because it's in this in the
media i can talk to that i'm so i'm i'm
sad that i'm not respecting the
confidentiality of the process of the
investigational report it's in the media
there is an allegation well you get it
you get the chance to defend yourself in
any case i mean you've been suspended
correct in the fall okay and you said
your university didn't even call you
when all this blew up and which is
typical in my experience of the way
institutions are reacting to this sort
of thing so an unnamed number of
students
made comments that you have views that
are in some
sense reprehensible even though you
don't know what they are and the
response of your university despite the
fact that you have tenure that you're an
accomplished scientist that you're a
popular undergraduate researcher that
you have tenure the response of your
university was to naughty call you but
suspend you for the fall what pending an
investigation an investigation into what
exactly have they told you what you did
wrong
of course i i saw those complaints um
and
i can tell you i think that part i can
say it is most of them are related to
the blog and that's fine people have the
right not to like uh what you say what i
say what anyone else is saying that's
fine but when we get into uh false
allegations
it's a different story there's also a
difference between having the right not
to like what you say on your blog
and aggregating behind your back and
conspiring to contact all your employers
and to insist that you be removed
because you're reprehensible and
hypothetically a danger to the let's say
the safety of students
and to have you removed from your
position and have your reputation
dragged through the mud and have you
exposed in the media i mean that's not
merely not liking what you said that's
an all-out attack and it's amazing to me
that the
this handful of students an unspecified
number has the power to move the
administration to
produce such a dramatic response and you
and you you keep um wavering in some
sense as to the nature of your crimes
you said you think it might you think
it's likely the blog but i guess there
are allegations that go outside the blog
as well have you ever had trouble with
your students in classes that have
resulted in complaints never all those
who know me personally who can guess who
i am in the blog because i think it
shows a little bit that i you know i
write
all right or write a lot so you can
guess you can see you can make links you
can see so for example i may criticize
a certain
politician and one on one blog but i can
say thank you on another one for doing
something good you know i'm writing
because we cannot comment on art media
articles um many times you know the
comment section is closed right so for
me it's my way of doing it so if if they
well it doesn't seem to me that it's
something that needs to be justified i
mean first of all
you're a citizen of a free country you
have a right to express yourself any way
that you see fit second of all you're a
tenured professor and your thoughts
actually protected to a fair degree and
it's protected broadly so that you can
think broadly and the fact that this has
happened despite your tenure well i
guess part of the question that people
who are watching might be asking is why
the hell should they care about this and
the reason i believe that people should
care about this first of all is that
what happens in the universities ends up
happening everywhere else very very
rapidly
and if it can happen to someone like you
it seems to me that it can happen to
anyone at any time in any place
and this this this unbelievable
cowardice that our institutions show in
the in the face of
unwarranted allegations as long as
they're the right flavor is something
that should be tremendously worrisome to
everyone tell us about no safe spaces
first and then tell us about you know
your your attempts to get it distributed
or the attempts to get it distributed
well i'll i'll start with the the movie
and then this will go on to the attempts
to be distributed um oh i actually
wanted it to reverse
okay
well that's fine
either way
uh
you know dennis and i are very different
we have very different backgrounds but
we do have
common sense in common and i have found
more and more and i'm assuming you guys
feel the same way which is just finding
someone with common sense seems to trump
all the other characteristics that we're
constantly talking about about you know
where what region you're born in or who
your team is or what color your skin is
uh dennis and i
always had common sense in common
and we struck up a great friendship
we've done many speaking engagements
we've always had a great time in each
other's company
and so when the producers came to us
with this idea uh i immediately jumped
at it just because it selfishly seemed
like we could spend a lot of time
together talking about a subject that
we're both pretty passionate about which
is free speech and
since the time we made this movie i i i
feel like things have gotten much worse
i think the
movie was
a bit ahead of its time in terms of
what it is the subject matter and now i
feel like in just the three or four
years since we started
this free speech issue
has gone into overdrive go ahead dennis
yeah
a word on the movie and then a word on
the distribution
i i've said from the beginning and i um
i i'm neither arrogant nor humble i i i
i just pretty much try to see myself in
life objectively
uh and i so i have said uh
this is a great movie
and it's not a great movie because i'm
in it might be a great movie because
adam is in it but
the truth is it's a great movie and adam
and i happen to be the quote-unquote
stars but that's not the point of the
movie
uh i have watched this about five times
i have the attention span of a child
and so for something to keep me riveted
five times uh speaks
immensely about it it is it is it truly
is an important movie it's more
important today even than when it was
made
about free speech and it's gotten movies
within the movies and anyway people
should see it
i'd like to point out too just just as
an advertisement of sorts there's a
canadian equivalent to that movie called
better left unsaid that has faced the
same sort of distribution problems that
you guys have faced and it focuses on
issues that are more germane to canada
although also relevant to the us and so
um well
do they deserve a note they did they
deserve to mention so i'm glad you
pointed out i happen to think that
things are worse in canada than in the
us
uh but uh that's an interesting
discussion for either another time or
later on uh today so what was your
impetus term for making i'm in the
movement of everybody talk about the
distribution yes yes netflix refused to
distribute it
uh uh to to stream it which is
incredible given how popular the movie
is
okay so make a case for that like why
okay so netflix should have been
incentivized as as far as you're
concerned by the fact that the movie was
economically successful and there are
other streaming agencies too online that
are fairly powerful so amazon etc
have you had any interest from any of
the streaming agencies yes well it's
interesting i don't know the i'll look
up the amazon question i know that the
walmart doesn't sell it in its stores
they they have the same thing
uh all you need really in in at netflix
or walmart or any of these is one or two
people
who are woke
uh to tell uh you know we can't do this
we're gonna get a bad name uh and and
then you know what what is it to netflix
not to listen to somebody says oh dennis
prager
we know we know for a fact that it was
my name that was the trigger
which is an interesting thing uh which i
one day would be fascinating to discuss
because whenever my name is is raised as
this bugaboo
i always say well can you say anything
in 35 years of broadcasting 10 books
literally 1 000 columns on the internet
plus tens of thousands of hours of the
radio recorded
say one thing that i have ever said
that strikes you as extreme
and so there's never an example this
literally never the new york times did a
piece on me they couldn't find one
sentence uh they made up something in
fact they said prager suggested
and i always tell people if they don't
say said
don't believe the line
suggested is the new york times not what
i said and then they had no quotes but
anyway
i've had the same experience dennis you
know i know
of course you have i know that
i can't find a thing you've ever said
that is an ennobling
i love your work i wrote the prep i
wrote the introduction to your biography
i had uh i had this experience as well
and then i have another thought which is
uh i got into a lot of trouble and i got
out of favor with critics because
um
it was widely
said that adam corolla said women
weren't funny
now this is perfect and you guys have
experienced a version of this i did an
interview years ago and the person said
at the end
who's funnier men or women
and i said well i think men are i think
it's based on them trying to have sex
essentially so they had to exercise that
muscle a little bit
but
i know many female comedians that are
funnier than anybody any guy ever went
to high school with
that then turned into adam carlos said
women weren't funny
and then they just ran with it
and that's up there
with that well look it's it's pretty
credible what you say because my sense
is is that
there's been a couple of things i've
said
that have been blown up in the press you
know and they were
exaggerations of the sort that you're
describing taken out of context
i think that in the current climate if
you've ever said anything reprehensible
on public record that you will be
slaughtered for it and so if you haven't
been slaughtered for it the probability
that you haven't said anything
reprehensible is pretty damn high
because
people are combing over the the
utterances of people like you trying to
find a smoking pistol i don't know if
you can comb over things to find a
smoking pistol but
i i was at a senate subcommittee on
the suppression of free speech
uh testifying about what's happening to
prageru where uh hundreds of our videos
are placed on the restricted list
meaning if you have a filter against
pornography and violence you actually
can't see the video so one of them was
in fact one one that i had given i only
give one tenth of the videos ninety
percent of other people but i i have
given a number of videos on the ten
commandments for example and so senator
ted cruz asked the representative of
google
why did you
people can see this on youtube it is
still there
why did you uh why did you put mr
prager's uh talk on
on uh
on the ten commandments on on the
restricted list
and the man looked at senator cruz and
said
because it mentions murder
and i remember i remember humming the
twilight zone theme because i i felt i
had entered an alternate universe so
what do you think the reason was dennis
i mean obviously look that's got to be a
bit of a pr nightmare for google to do
something like that so it smacks of a
certain degree of incompetence to begin
with and i i like to hypothesize
incompetence before malevolence
so so why do you think it was censored
that specifically and then why with
regards to is it reasonable to call
what's happening with prageru censorship
and why do you think it's happening
because well i'll tell you the the i'll
answer the last one first and this will
help
you realize that i think there's more
malevolence than incompetence
there is never an instance in the
history of the world and this is my
field of study since i was in graduate
school at colombia that's why i studied
russian was to read pravda and visit the
soviet union on multiple occasions and
other and other communist countries
there is no instance in world history
that is since the russian revolution of
the left gaining power and not
suppressing speech liberals offer free
speech conservatives are for free speech
the left has never been for free speech
okay so let me ask you a clarifying
question there all right because
you know i come i'm a canadian and
i suppose along with the scandinavian
countries were tilted a fair degree to
the left compared to the us
and so i mean freedom of speech is
in reasonable shape in our countries
those countries that i mentioned and so
when you talk about the left
tell me more specifically what you mean
and how you would define that particular
state
because you're not talking about the
democrats per se i can't imagine or
perhaps you are the democrats used to be
i was a democrat the democrats used to
be liberal the democrats when i was a
kid in the 70s
nazis real nazis not people they just
call nazis real nazis with swastikas
uh demonstrated in uh in skokie illinois
because a lot of jews lived there
especially holocaust survivors it was a
particularly vicious act
and uh jewish groups the aclu liberal
groups the democratic party all defended
their right
because in america anybody could say
anything except yelp fire in a crowded
theater that is no longer the position
you you look you're why did you why did
you get in trouble
and you're right you're i've wondered
about that for a long time okay so
well no uh
well i'm
if you're wondering i'm not
you uh you said something the left
didn't like that you were not going to
be told by the government what pronoun
you will use we need institutions that
we can respect and that
and that hold up the standards that have
made them what they are and if they fold
well how can you expect
normal people say not to be cowed and
intimidated by the same tactics
absolutely absolutely actually there
were two other episodes on my mind one
of which sort of confirmed my theory
about what was happening in your case
the other of which suggested different
sorts of motivations so one of them was
a case that occurred around the same
time as yours which was a case of a
research fellow at saint evans college
here in cambridge
who was doing research he's a
sociologist a very well-known
respectable sociologist he had workers
work profiled in the economist in top
journals um he was fired because there
was a again there was a more protesting
about his associations conferences he'd
been to journals that he published in
which other people that they found
distasteful and published and so on
again donald said nothing illegal that
was one case which again i think
illustrates the sorts of pressures that
i think will be brought to bear what
were the topics for that
the topic is race and intelligence yes
yes yes well the intelligence literature
is
is rough
that's for sure i mean the whole the
whole thing is was so chilling because
it was it was decided by an inquiry that
was kept secret nobody's going to know
what the evidence was in this inquiry um
so the whole thing was was terrifying um
the other case was slightly different so
there was another case that concerned me
which was a case where it was a it was
an event for the palestinian society
where there was a chair from that
society
was the university threatened to shut
down because they thought they were
worried that the chair might be an
extremist or something she wasn't at all
she was a respectful respectable
academic from soas um and the university
imposed its own its own chair on that
now that was slightly different because
that was responding to another another
threat of free speech which is the
government's legislation on prevent and
anti-terrorism um but those three events
were sort of coalescing in my mind
around the time that i tried to change
the um
change the university's free speech
policy
okay so what did so let's talk about the
change in the free speech policy what
what changes did you propose and then it
took a couple of years as i understand
to really get this
through
and i also understand from james that
it wasn't that easy to get people to
speak in favor of your proposal but that
it was passed and we need to go into
that by an overwhelming majority of the
people who were concerned and able to
legislate such things so to speak for
the university
yeah so i can take you through that what
happened was it was this was around
actually march 2020 so about a year
after your your case and
the university had decided that it was
going to put through a new freedom of
speech policy um
uh this is obviously at a time when
everyone had had other things on their
mind at least in britain in march 2020.
they didn't offer a vote on it they just
wanted to put it straight through and it
was a policy which i found concerning
especially in life of things incidents
um one part of it was that it mandates
said that we have right free speech but
we must always exercise respect for
other people's identities
and opinions now that might seem
innocuous um
uh but of course the word respect being
so vague
it doesn't seem innocuous to me
i mean it seems terrible because it just
it just removes the first part of
protection for free speech i mean if you
have to be cautious about other people's
opinions
much less their identity well we should
reverse that their identity much less
their opinions is well who decides when
that's respectful and what yeah yeah
it's just weasel words that exactly and
the bit about identities i bet they had
you in mind when they were saying that
actually um uh
uh but whenever anyone says i believe in
free speech but that's a good sign to me
that they don't believe in free speech
and that was the impression that this
policy gave off other parts of the
policy um which may not have been
directly explicitly new but which
certainly brought you and those other
cases for instance the palestinian
society to mind
were rules which said that the
university could stop speaker events if
they thought they would threaten the
welfare of students there's no wealth
welfare is defined to get undefined and
could be interpreted broadly
and indeed allowed the university to
stop events under pretty much any
circumstances that they like speaker
events for instance
so those were the that was the proposed
policy in march 2020 so why did that why
did that bother you so much i mean
you're pretty young and and and starting
your academic career in many ways
maybe i'm wrong about that but
you know it's a hell of a thing to take
on and it's not without its risks and
i'm always curious about people's
motives it's like there's lots of
professors at cambridge why why do you
think this was your problem
well you flattened me by the young but
i will say that i guess there were two
things one of them was philosophical one
was more to do with the nature of the
job so philosophically speaking my basic
philosophical position is what you might
call classical liberal so my basic value
is individual liberty um
and uh you know i would in terms of what
what i do my political engagement um
even my professional engagement to some
extent you know that's the the ultimate
and most important important value so
for me it really touched a nerve um
it touched something that was the core
of my identity if you want to use that
that um appalling word um the other
aspect which i said was professional was
simply to do something i alluded to
earlier which was what is this job for
it's part of your duty as an academic i
would have thought you know academics
are normally cautious as they should be
but the one thing that they shouldn't be
cautious about is defending the ultimate
purpose of the academy and that cannot
be um pursued without free speech um and
without the ability to question freely
um beliefs that are held by the majority
also beliefs that are held by minorities
and without worrying about who you're
going to offend who's going to be hurt
by your words especially a in a subject
like philosophy and i dare say something
like yours and certainly in a subject
like james's you know you can't have
free discussion if every time you talk
about something you're frightened that
you're going to offend the other person
and then they might report you and you
might get in trouble i can't do my job i
don't expect james can i think but you
can if discussion is curtailed in that
way so well no scientists can because
that freedom of inquiry and the freedom
to upset traditional truths let's say
well in some in a more really
fundamental sense that's what science is
all about and
as a
let's say a creative scientist you're
always working against
what's established because otherwise
what you discovered wouldn't be new and
you're always going to be facing people
who are upset for one reason or another
by your hypothesis and your research so
it's it's it's not it's not a side uh
issue here it's it's crucial to the
academy as such yeah absolutely it's
it's absolutely but that still doesn't
explain why you made it your problem say
when so many people were perfectly
willing to remain silent well one thing
i would say was that i was like i was
slightly surprised
when i wrote so after after the
university's policy came out
there was a discussion what's called the
discussion in cambridge university
really means that you write a paper and
it's it's published in the university
magazine um and so i sent a short paper
off proposing some changes to these
policies and stating my objections and i
had expected this being cambridge
university that many other people would
do the same um because i didn't think i
was alone in being concerned about this
um
uh nobody else did so i was that was the
first point of which i i realized so
there was no there was no real braver on
my heart because i had expected at that
point that a lot of people a lot of
other people would be would be jumping
in um
nobody did so that was the point at
which i realized that i was perhaps more
isolated
than i'd expected um
to go back to your question about
motivation and i don't know what more i
can tell you i mean these are things
that matter to me i don't really care if
anyone else is doing it or not and did
you face any trouble so you voiced your
opinion and you wanted to modify this
this document which had let's say
politically correct underpinnings and
did it cause grief for you were were
people outraged by what you said or or
did things proceed as a matter of course
well it was interesting so some people
uh some people wrote to me in fact quite
a few people wrote to me at the time
saying that they agreed with with my
concerns um which sort of made it even
more surprising that nobody had actually
said so in public um some people wrote
to me saying they agree with my concerns
that weren't willing to to say anything
in public um
uh james was was as always was
brilliantly helpful james has always
been really supportive and james has
been publicly supported
throughout this process but it's because
there have been a few courageous people
like james and a few others you know in
cambridge at that stage that was
definitely a big a big help um so there
was some support i also had people
warning me so i had people saying you
know you might get you know you might
get some kind of disciplinary procedure
you might get some kind of investigation
i didn't expect anything at that stage
and indeed nothing happened um to me at
that stage and i'm pleased to say
there'd be no investigations or anything
out of me of me since um so that's
really interesting in two ways isn't it
because
it shows you how loath people are to do
this because they're afraid and we
shouldn't make light of that because
this is actually no fun
you know if if you do something like
this and it explodes in your face like
it it probably took me
oh it took me a long time to recover
from the disinvitation especially the
way it was handled and my health and my
wife's health were extremely compromised
at the time and so it came at a
a particularly bad time we had just
received news that she probably had
terminal cancer and so this came on top
of that now luck that she survived thank
god but you know it was a harrowing time
and so i i see why people can be cowed
like this because
you know you don't know when this is
going to explode and it's going to
tangle you up so deeply that while your
job's gone that's what happened to the
weinsteins for example at evergreen and
i mean
that was really that did them a
tremendous amount of damage they're
unbelievably resourceful and they got
back on their feet
and and you know they were a husband and
wife team so they had each other and
that was good but not everybody can do
that and you can get seriously taken out
if if something like this goes wrong
so
but then that ties into this issue we
discussed a bit earlier which is how a
small minority of you know people who
whose wrath knows no bounds in some
sense can be so dominant yeah
so it was it was it was in some ways a
calculated risk and i i mean i can't
imagine how difficult that must have
been for you jordan it was it would you
know it must have been horrific um
i mean one thing i saw happening in
cambridge not right not quite then but a
little bit later was the treatment
that was meted out to not an academic
but to a member of the university staff
so we have we have college porters in
cambridge and these are these people who
work at the colleges um uh often they're
they're sort of you know retired
policemen or military or something um
really helpful they do all kinds of jobs
around the college students rely on them
the academics rely on them the ones in
my college brilliant
there was one at a college in cambridge
who was also a labour counselor um
who uh who resigned on political grounds
which was to do with his view about
about trans issues so he thought it was
you know
there was there was emotion about trans
issues that he thought you know
threatened women's safety and so he
resigned on a point of principle and
that's his political activity that's his
right i could i could understand his
grants for doing that
the students at his college so these are
typically much more privileged people
than him students at his college formed
the mob to try to get this man sacked um
and this was this was you know this is a
much more privileged people they didn't
care about you know the consequences for
him they just thought because he
diverted from their line of ideological
purity do you remember this case james
and james may know what did you leave it
yeah
i do it was thanks to a very brave
female undergraduate i think she was in
her even her second year she spoke out
uh wrote a public article about it a
great courage uh i thought to herself
and she uh there was an awful lot of
resistance to her doing that but uh it
was remarkable she got in touch with us
i seem to remember and i can't remember
how the case was resolved did you ever
apologize did you or did you what
happened with you apologize for what
well that's the cool for whatever you
were being accused of
i never apologized for
um
refusing to comply with my university's
mandate
i never apologized for speaking publicly
about it
i never have and won't apologize for
continuing to try to have discussions
about the truth that doesn't mean that i
or who i'm talking with will will always
get it right surely we'll make mistakes
everyone makes mistakes the truth isn't
a set of facts the truth is an approach
to dial to discussion
that's what joe rogan's so good at
that's why he's so popular it's not
because joel
knows the truth it's because he acts out
the truth
in his in his in his in in his speech
and his actions
so yeah that's a whole different thing
whole different thing well solzhenitsyn
was convinced that
a totalitarian state could not exist
unless everyone was participating in the
lie
and that the most potent
anti-authoritarian
action is
to tell the truth
and and that means to say something when
you have something to say because the
old not because you're brave but i think
but because the alternative is worse
yeah that's
and it was orwell it's so so interesting
to me that it was orwell that that that
opened your eyes to that i mean it makes
perfect sense but but it's still really
something
yeah i know it's like uh
that like that book i think that's when
i realized oh everybody was responsible
and
that's when i started thinking about
speaking out
that's when you started thinking about
speaking out i see i see and so you made
a conscious decision at that point
yeah
why
why because i knew the price of silence
because
like that that was surprising real pain
right like not even knowing like
that's the thing like when people said
why no revolutions because we don't know
we are slaves in north korea how do you
fight to be free when you don't know
you're a slave
and that's a different thing like the
fact that my people don't even know
they're oppressed
that's the thing like what carries me to
this point about my father is
not like he
i of course i would be grateful he'll
ever lived in freedom in one day but
the heartbreaking thing is he didn't
even know
life could be this free and life could
be this beautiful
he didn't even know that like
life could be so different for other
human beings
i just wish he knew before he goes so he
doesn't remember his
life so her heart is fairly the sadness
you know
and that's the thing with north koreans
we are talking a different theory of
oppression you don't even know life can
be this way
and
yeah so that was my time of
understanding what happened
and started believing in this freedom